avec eux on aime beaucoup interrogé les
français à l'aide de sondages qu'ils
nous croient vraiment valeur de sondage
qui sont ce qu'on appelle dans notre
jargon des micro trottoirs et qui nous
permettent un peu de sentir le pouls
sinon de la population disons d'une
partie dans de cette population et
gérard pas bio aime beaucoup cela
évidemment il s'est immédiatement
intéresser à tout ce qui s'est passé
juste après les élections puisque on en
sort tout juste et vrai découvrir c'est
pas triste
par exemple de ces villes qui sont
passées à droite à droite sur une
cartographie bon qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
pris comme point de repère pour centrer
la carte est ce qu'ils ont pris à
méridien qui est toujours le même
où est-ce qu'ils ont pris un autre
méridien c'est ça le problème en je vous
pose la question la jolie les villes qui
sont passés à droite oui mais moi je
peux pas vous discuté avec vous si vous
ne montrez pas un papier sur lequel
s'est dessinée quand je vous parle de
ballotage voyait ce dont il est question
monsieur qu'est ce que c'est le
ballottage est à dire que c'est comme on
veut
oui alors qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire
pour suivre email ballottage par exemple
vouloir occuper apporter des soutiens
wade a soutenu qu'on voit pas ça tous
les temps comme ça que je vois dans le
journal là il est question de
la douche froide à gauche oui alors
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais moi je
dis c'est complètement idiot
pourquoi la douche froide à bouger la
douche chaude à droite plus mais l'enjeu
c'est aussi bien il est question de
changement de mode de scrutin qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
scrutin à part dieu khach arabe
connais pas
et puis pour s'habiller nous on tient
pas compte de la mode dont sa vie la
balance commerciale vous voyez ce que
c'est alors comment l avis assez d'une
balance quand même que déjà importantes
comme ça quoi
et autant mais alors comme vous dites
que oui les questions de déficit de la
balance commerciale que le commerçant
plaindrait qu'il soit déficient déficit
au point de vue de certains temps de
votre avis moi je vous propose vous avez
des petites et les grandes
d'abord si vous allez chez le marchand
de poisson et haute d'une balance que
qui correspond déjà pas mal commercial
commercial
on verra si vous allez chez trois mois
chez le boucher
certains bouchers dans les centre
commercial d'abord on les voit pas parce
que c'est préparer je vois que la
balance commerciale s'est préparé deux
jours c'est les fans mais alors ce
déficit de la balance commerciale qu'est
ce qu'il faut en penser
il faudrait être réellement commerçants
pour le prouver
qu'est ce que c'est que l'opep ces deux
loups m
c'est dire paix
qu'est ce que c'est l'open les eaux
dangereuses alors les pays de l'opep est
ce que ce serait je connais pas je vous
ai dit que les jattes alors à votre avis
c'est que l'étranger payer des gens qui
feraient de l'eau gazeuse ben probable
allez peut-être cette enfance je prends
quoi à l'opac blau c'est la prod qui
fabriquent nos propres toi maintenant
quelles stars elles qui a été élu à
nîmes voyez qu'on n'est pas très loin de
l'actualité
[Musique]